all eyes here in kigali will be looking
back to you back to the uk and the prime
minister will be watching these two
by-elections nervously what can i tell
you uh tonight well my latest uh intel
information i've got is that on
wakefield uh the labour target seat
labor source is telling me that they're
feeling good about that by-election i'm
told that they're not expecting an
enormous win but they're hoping for a
solid one so it looks like according to
labor it will fall to them that was kind
of expected but tiverton down in devon
it's a huge conservative majority the
lib dems would have to overturn a 24 000
majority they'd have to do it from third
place because labour came second in the
2019 general election what's the vibe
down there well according to my lib dem
sources
one told me tonight
that they know the swing towards them
will be big they don't know if it will
be enough to take the seat one said to
me it's going to go to the wire and then
said we could
do it
if they do do it as i said they'll be
wiping out a 24 000 conservative
majority it will be a record breaker
overturning a 40.7
tory majority there and it would be the
tory's worst ever election result so as
boris johnson tonight meets with world
leaders he's at an event tonight he will
be going to bed watching nervously
overnight to see those by-election
results coming